con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a hablar de las elecciones de
medio término de Estados Unidos donde
los demócratas se juegan en control de
los dos de las dos cámaras del congreso
este próximo martes 8 de noviembre Rosa
Pérez está con nosotros en el estudio
también para seguir analizando pues toda
esta situación y lo vamos a hacer con el
doctor Guillermo Pacheco Él es director
Internacional del Security College en
Estados Unidos o Guillermo muy buen día
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana jueves en directo América de
Francia 24 y empecemos por esbozar un
poco el panorama general de estas
elecciones de medio término como llegan
estos dos partidos tanto los demócratas
y los republicanos no que esto Pues los
republicanos también llegan reforzados y
los demócratas no también parados no
Saúl Buenos días gusto saludarte y sí
Mira es estamos ya casi a seis días de
las de las elecciones pareciera que como
tú muy bien lo dices los que más
reforzado llegan son los republicanos y
los demócratas en una en una picada no
sé cómo puede estar pero creo que vamos
a tener el martes vamos a tener un nuevo
panorama político en los Estados Unidos
y Guillermo Buenos días
recientemente sin ir más lejos ayer
mismo baile no expresó la preocupación
que hay por una creciente violencia
política en el país y que ojalá no sea
así pero podría desencadenar escenarios
violentos durante la jornada electoral
del martes sin embargo desde hace años
que los servicios de inteligencia que el
departamento de interior de Estados
Unidos considera que la principal
amenaza para la seguridad del país son a
las grupos de extrema derecha algo ha
cambiado se ha intensificado esta
amenaza y también completo
Santa Rosa y Guillermo por el episodio
que vimos recientemente este ataque
contra el esposo de Nancy pero sí que
presuntamente también era contra ella no
Exacto Fíjate que me parece que el tema
de la de la seguridad en Estados Unidos
Sí sí se está complicando No creo yo que
sea
relacionado específicamente a estas
elecciones evidentemente los extremismos
desde mi punto de vista no solo si se
puede llamar de derecha sino también de
izquierda han sido muy patentes en en
los Estados Unidos evidentemente se ha
dado mucho énfasis al al a los de
derecha pero de izquierda digo los otros
grupos también están muy presentes y en
el caso de de del ataque a la casa de
Nancy pelosi y a su a su esposo
específicamente por pelosi Me parece que
fue algo algo
salido de de un complot por decirlo así
me parece que fue alguien solo alguien
que intentó como querer mandar un
mensaje pero solo no me parece que sea
parte de algo más grande en el tema de
seguridad así evidencia
sin lugar a dudas un problema de
seguridad Rosa sí Guillermo usted
menciona y también hay amenazas por
parte de grupos de izquierda nos podría
dar algún ejemplo Sí mira evidentemente
todos estos grupos relacionados a lo que
hemos conocido como
Black matters y todo lo que tiene que
ver con estas con con con estas
tendencias hacen ciertos ataques
específicos que no los vemos tan Por
decirlo así tan puestos en los medios de
comunicación como estos ataques me
explico y quedan Al mismo nivel
evidentemente El ataque de Nancy pelosi
y a la perdón a la casa Nancy pelosi
tiene un un papel más protagónico pero
aquí en los Estados Unidos aquí en los
Estados Unidos también sobre todo en
Washington DC y ciertas zonas de
Washington DC lo que más vemos son
ataques digamos o presencias y ataques
de este tipo Entonces yo veo en este
caso el el incremento de la inseguridad
en los Estados Unidos desde estos
extremismos de derecha izquierda que
pueden ir creciendo en base a lo que de
aquí al 2024 políticamente empecemos a
ver Guillermo muriendo al terreno
electoral hablemos de la importancia del
voto latino para estos comicios del 8 de
noviembre
Mira esta es una muy buena pregunta Raúl
Me parece que está dándose un un balance
nuevamente un reposicionamiento por
decirse así en las últimas encuestas
análisis se vio como los hispanos están
empezando a votar hacia los republicanos
ha habido una tendencia de que los los
latinos los hispanos aquí los Estados
Unidos en estas elecciones del próximo
martes vamos a tener una mayor presencia
votando a los a los republicanos podemos
entender esto como importante porque el
número de votantes hispanos en los
Estados Unidos está creciendo Y que el
voto normalmente ha sido hacia los los
demócratas entonces que tengamos un
reposicionamiento de este voto hacia los
republicanos esto lo que hace es que va
a inclinar en el caso de la cámara de
representante muchos votos hacia hacia
representantes que es lo que puede darse
una mayoría republicana en la cámara de
representantes entonces la el poder por
decirlo así del voto hispano está
creciendo en cuanto al reposicionamiento
que están teniendo ahora hacia los
republicanos
y Guillermo estas elecciones de medio
término son en general una referéndum
también a la mandato del presidente en
el cargo Cómo se valora Cuáles son los
principales Reproches o los principales
aciertos que se hacen a John vayan
Mira es una muy buena pregunta porque
entendamos esto lo que va a pasar el
martes ocurre cada 12 años me explico
cada 12 años lo que se juega es 66% del
senado y 100% de la cámara
representantes la anterior vez que pasó
Le pasó en su primer mandato al
presidente Obama y perdió ambas cámaras
siendo el presidente Obama en este
tiempo dos temas muy importantes que la
la población en los Estados Unidos está
resintiendo primero de la parte
económica aquí normalmente en Estados
Unidos la parte económica determina
muchas veces el voto y el tema el de la
recesión que el gobierno no quiere
aceptar y el tema por ejemplo de los
precios de la gasolina van a determinar
en mucho el tema El el tema del voto es
el próximo el próximo martes y segundo
es ese ese posicionamiento internacional
que para muchos dentro de Estados Unidos
no es satisfactorio en cuanto a la
política de biden respecto a Ucrania por
ejemplo y respecto a otros aspecto otros
temas de política exterior que antes no
se manejaban de esta manera el el caso
de la recesión unido a la cantidad de
miles de millones que se le están
enviando a Ucrania al interno de los
Estados Unidos va a determinar mucho
este voto para para para el tema
baile y un tercer punto que no sé cómo
puede ser verse si positivo o negativo
es el tema de la inmigración el tema de
la inmigración es un tema que en los
Estados Unidos Igualmente se conoce poco
pero solo en entre agosto y septiembre
un número
180.000 inmigrantes ilegales entraron
por la por la frontera Entonces es un
tema que también para
positivo Porque pueden entrar los
familiares que están esperando pero para
el interno Es complicado